[Music]
how did free-trade develop in the Middle
Ages this was standard practice
merchants paid tolls at bridges mountain
passes and city gates when they moved
goods from one Principality to the next
many came via the sea they loaded up
boats with fish and preserved them in
salt or put brandy and the wine to stop
it going bad clever moves but they still
couldn't find a way to avoid those pesky
tolls the merchants wanted them
abolished and they also wanted to defend
themselves against pirates and thieves
on dangerous trade routes so they joined
forces in northern Europe they founded
that German Hanseatic League and knew
back in 1280 it was a great
international alliance a confederation
of merchants from large cities that soon
began to grow first Hamburg then Rostock
and cologne cities much farther away
soon set up hands at trading posts to
buy the 14th century the league included
almost 200 cities the cog is the vessel
most closely associated with this
trading network a lot of goods fit into
its voluminous haul Hanseatic merchants
were the global players of the age they
could speak foreign languages and were
generally well educated rich and had
great political influence but the
Hanseatic League never became a proper
free trade zone in 1800 much instill had
to pay customs duties in 41 different
German states and free cities but
increasingly the idea of free trade
caught on in 1833 the german customs
union created a large tariffs free area
over a century later the foundation for
free trade in europe was laid the
European Coal and Steel community was
the forerunner of the European Union
which today guarantees free trade among
its member states
the motive was not just economic the
idea was to create a system of shared
values after all increasing trade also
plays a role in promoting peace
[Music]